et pour en parler vincent chauvet maire
modem de la ville d'autun nous a rejoint
vincent chauvet merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors votre
commune est concernée par un second tour
alors juin ou janvier quelle date
défendez vous pour ce second tour
finalement je crois que tous les
responsables politiques disent la même
chose on a eu un premier tour et l'idéal
serait d'avoir un deuxième tour le plus
rapidement possible mais il y a à la
fois la question de l'épidémie où en
sera tôt et puis la question
démocratique est ce que nous aurons plus
de participation on a vu qu'elle aime
beaucoup d'abstention pour le premier
tour ça remet en cause la légitimité du
scrutin
et pour savoir si les personnes âgées
notamment les personnes en
établissements pourront aller voter si
on peut pas faire de porte à porte pas
faire de réunions publiques
je rappelle qu'en france le scrutin par
correspondance hormis dans les français
de l'étranger et le scrutin par internet
ne sont pas encore la règle ça paraît
compliqué d'avoir une élection je
voudrais quand même dire les difficultés
que nous avons à ne pas tenir des
élections pendant une période prolongée
c'est que les maires sont aussi
représentant dans des organismes qui
gèrent l'eau qui gère les déchets dans
des communautés de communes des
communautés d'agglomération qui auront
des élus de millésimes différents
certains élus au premier tour donc en
mars
et puis d'autres qui attendront un
second tour qui attendent en ce moment à
un second tour
et c'est pas forcément très simple pour
gérer ces mécanismes intercommunaux
ensuite il y a toute la question de
savoir s'il y a encore une légitimité à
pouvoir faire un deuxième tour plus de
trois mois après le premier alors que la
crise a gelé toute expression partisane
même si grâce à un certain nombre de
dispositions législatives
les maires ont pu passer des budgets ont
pu obtenir des conseils municipaux ça a
été le cas de la commune de tincques
tenu deux conseils municipaux en
visioconférence et qui a passé déjà un
budget et un budget rectificatif donc la
vie n'est pas bloqué mais la vie
démocratique est un petit peu en suspens
il faudrait selon vous refaire
finalement
deux tours si le scrutin était amené à
se refaire plus tard au mois de janvier
notamment
alors c'est ce que le conseil d'état
avait dit en disant que si l'élection ne
pouvait pas se tenir avant l'été
j'observe d'ailleurs peu de gens le
disent mais que 28 juin 7 après le début
de l'été après le 21 juin
il faudrait refaire les deux tours moi
j'ai une position un peu particulière
parce que je suis aussi élu d'une ville
dans un territoire rural le morvan en
bourgogne et jeudi on pourrait presque
faire trois tours en fait aujourd'hui il
ya des communes qui ont élu au premier
tour
l'ensemble du conseil municipal et qui
vont dans les prochains jours dans les
prochaines heures élire leurs maires
très bien et puis ensuite il y a deux
types de scrutin si vous êtes dans une
ville de plus de 1000 habitants vous
avez aucun élu qui a été élu au premier
tour et puis vous avez donc un deuxième
tour pour élire l'ensemble du conseil
municipal
si vous êtes dans une ville de moins de
1000 habitants par panachage vous avez
parfois un seulement ou deux du conseil
municipal qui n'ont pas été élus et et
90% du conseil municipal qui est déjà
élu au premier tour
on pourrait presque faire dans ces
communes où il ne reste plus que 1 ou 2
conseillers à lire et parfois ce sont
les seuls candidats faire les élections
assez vite et on aura peu de
participation mais au final il n'y aura
pas de problème de légitimité
démocratique puisque ce sont les seuls
candidats et que même s'ils ne sont pas
élus la majorité dans ces conseils
municipaux et déjà acquise
et puis dans les grandes villes
notamment paris dans les villes urbaines
dans les métropoles qui nécessite un
deuxième tour de le faire pourquoi pas
en juin avec des listes remaniée mais il
faudra dans ces cas-là penser aux
candidats qui ont fait des recours aux
candidats qui ont engagé des dépenses
parce que nous notre parti le modem nous
avions prônée depuis plusieurs années
avec d'autres partis d'ailleurs l'idée
d'une banque de la démocratie qu'ils
puissent préfinancer les candidats quand
leur candidature est acceptée et
aujourd'hui cette réforme n'est toujours
pas en place et un certain nombre de
candidats ont fait des si ce n'est tous
ont fait des prêts personnels de parfois
de manière importante pour financer leur
campagne avant qu'elle ne leur soient
remboursés par l'état s'ils respectent
les règles et il faudra que
le gisti l'acteur prévoit comment on
assure l'égal accès aux scrutins
notamment d'un point de vue financier
je pense que les questions démocratiques
sont très importantes il faudra un
alignement entre conditions sanitaires
et conditions démocratiques je crois que
finalement dans l'ensemble du spectre
politique c'est ce que disent à leur
manière chacun des responsables
pour conclure en quelques mots que vous
disent vos administrés est-ce qu'ils ont
peur aujourd'hui d'aller voter alors
aujourd'hui on voit que le déconfinement
et très progressif
nous sommes dans un département rouge il
y a eu dix décès à l'hôpital d'autun
dont je suis le président du conseil de
surveillance depuis le début de
l'épidémie encore 1 la semaine dernière
les hôtels cafés restaurants n'ont pas
réouvert les écoles n'accueille que 20%
des enfants les collèges sont fermés et
on regarde quand on regarde les rues les
espaces publics il y a très peu de monde
dans les rues donc aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas de retour à la normale et il est
évident que si dimanche
fin mai nous donnions des élections nous
aurions un taux de participation très
faible donc que sera l'état d'esprit de
la population fin juin je ne sais pas
mais en tout cas aujourd'hui tout le
monde n'a pas encore confiance pour
ressortir dans la rue ou ressortir pour
aller voter
merci beaucoup vincent chauvet d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes le maire modem de la commune
de teint